[Applause]
a how you doing today how's white
supremacy doing I'm non-binary so okay
what do you go by Kai how can I refer to
you tonight Kai okay hey I'm smelling
alcohol I know how much have you
consumed tonight like probably through
drams stand facing me please but I just
want you know that I also have very bad
social anxiet
you and me both any recent head trauma
traumatic brain injuries anything I need
to know about uh mental yes as you know
as an indigenous person and there's a
bunch of [__] going
around I'm sorry but it's just for me to
be on my toes I get you with your arms
by your side just like this ma'am can
you not call me ma'am please I'm trying
my
heart yo this br going through a
checklist uh in in a minute she's
measured the fact that she's indigenous
that she got social anxiety that she got
mental health problems and the fact that
she's non-binary and she doesn't want
you calling her ma'am I'm trying my
hardest okay well okay it means a lot to
me I'm trying my hardest I don't feel
like a man so okay it's kind of
triggering hey you know what's going to
make this DUI stop go even better if I
tell the cop he's misgendering Me Maybe
if I make him feel guilty about gender
[__] he might just let me off the
hook cuz he don't want to seem like a
bigot
uh black people would like to disagree
with that say that again I said black
people would like to disagree with that
notion I'm black yeah stupid uh put the
cffs on this one they don't give a
killed
someone they don't give a the same way
you said everybody else and you got on
the road with your drink ass everybody
else gets to say you and what you
whining about you didn't care about
nobody else's safety why should we care
about your emotional state girl stop I'm
sorry it's a h man thing just like
I apologize let's see if we can move
forward from it you have zero
questions no but I just want to tell you
that I suffer from really bad anxiety
especially with generational trauma and
ptsc around n n n n n nah nah nah you
know what you know n you know what's
also you know what's red peeled me bro
you know what's red peeled me what
genuin you know what's red peed me
a bunch of women have told me that soon
as the traffic stops starts they start
crying oh yeah so well that's just yeah
they they just they start putting on the
Waterworks yeah and it helps them yeah
they've had like tickets reduced in
terms of like 10 kmet so it wouldn't get
certain demer point like they put so I
hear te listen I already hear women
crying and I'm like okay cool story then
I hear them cry D and the tra traffic
stop I get even less sympathy to me it
does the opposite it I'm going be really
odest
you
now oh
yeah yeah yeah when you do that stuff
I'm like G no ever since fresh F got
banned off YouTube sometimes my balls
tingle
too like when a woman cries oh yeah
absolutely can we go back to the video
sure anxiety
especially with generational trauma
suffer from really bad anxiety
especially with generational trauma and
ptsc
around white people and
cops yo she's just pulling out
everything at the rabbit yeah at the
rabbit has you pulling out everything
she said generational trauma PTSD Native
American
nonbinary uh sexually exclusive uh ma'am
don't call me ma'am please get my
pronouns right
what else what else we miss when you
want to pull that card you at least have
to wait cards there's like seven cards
hold up how many cards hold on when you
want to pull that deck is that
better when you want to pull that deck
you at least have to have something to
back it
up like dude is straight up asking you
question about something that he he
noticed noticed alcohol you drank so
it's hard to be like
you drank if someone pulls me over for
something that I did and come to find
out I didn't do I'm like okay so what's
your real reason you can start to and
and you you question and then the
person's
like then you can understand okay so
what but now there was literally nothing
hey sorry I did my I'm doing my best all
right cool all right let's do this can
you please he says please and thank
you C say please and thank you
and you going to you going to you're
going to pull out the deck oh my girl
you're not the one go ahead and place
your hands behind your back don't dude
please don't make it hard hey it's not
dude it's officer flashback what's going
on nothing why are you driving in the
wrong way of traffic no I just got
changed around I just moved here like 2
months ago and I just got changed around
okay do you understand what's going on
though tring on the wrong side of
traffico
all right this video is way worse than I
thought it was wait wait that's not even
the same
person Persona wise her voice and
everything that is not even the same
person bro they got a checklist the
water War come came nah yeah okay well
we're past that just go ahead and step
out I'll walk you back to my patrol car
and then I'll talk to you back
there sorry just like as an indigenous
person all yeah we need to counter for
how many times this lady said indigenous
I'm going to speak with you right over
here okay no yes ma'am go ahead and
place your hands behind your back don't
dude please don't make it hard no you're
you're going to get a resistance dude I
you're going to get a resist I don't
don't resist don't listen to me don't
resist don't you're being a white man
and
[Applause]
don't
a yo that's a new move that's a new one
I a heard that one before [__]
y i a never heard that one before that's
a wow you're making me sign with the
cops my girl come here don't I ain't
followed all of her [__] like don't
resist no yeah followed all of her [__]
don't
resist I fall you
yeah good good good don't ever [__] D
drink and drive stupid you had no
sympathy for me and there's ever a time
where I don't give a how they arrest
your ass is when you drink and drive cuz
that's just you as a citizen saying you
don't give a about no other people on
the road how many times do we have to
see these fing idiots get on the road
kill a family kill an individual kill
someone just walking down the goddamn
street right and then we all going to be
like but you want me to have sympathy
for you when you put everyone at risk
get okay is he being a white man I hope
he be more of a white man and [__] your
arms up so you can't get behind the
steering wheel again yeah stop drinking
and driving you get no sympathy for
me I the magicious person like [__] you
guys yo using your identity every 2
seconds is wild it's cringe what do you
have in your mouth nothing what do you
have in your mouth nothing you guys are
just scaring me lift your tongue lift
your tongue for me you guys are scaring
me there's nothing going to be afraid of
yes there is it's called [__]
generational
traa yo this girl's like a stupid robot
you ask her a question she just programs
it with some sjw answer ask me a
question how you doing today how's white
supremacy
doing that was a good one go ahead ask
me another one you're good ask me
another one my robot's on okay hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on would
you eat what I didn't eat was what white
people eat cuz they get access to the
good food through system
okay you're good at this all right all
right you're a white male that's what
you are as a black
person that's what you are y you're a
white
man yeah yeah you don't think I don't
know my [__] I've been around these
people I work in the Arts go ahead ask
something El okay so what do you do for
a living he wants me to ask me to
participate in
capitalism I don't subscribe to your
systems of colonialism and exp
patriotism of of imperialism do you have
a
girlfriend is that
Lu do you have a do you have a
girlfriend is there time for romance
under
tyranny do you have the ability to
invest yourself in someone that's going
to be stopped by cops
penetrated by the law and then oppressed
and compressed by systems of Oppression
ask yourself would you want to bring a
child into this world I didn't think so
okay no more questions cuz I have social
anxiety and I'm being this person
[__]
[__] have a seat no have a seat I
mean I will but like can I just see you
guys are being [__] [__] about
somebody who suffers for generational
pdsd and depression and Suicidal
Tendencies when yo this girl just ring
them [__] off wow but you know what I
have to say this in her defense the more
you talk the more you sound drunk the I
have to say this in her defense go ahead
she only talks like this cuz it's
worked she only is programmed this way
to respond this often because in
whatever environment that she's lived in
that [__] works that's possible right so
when she comes into this situation she's
using that same but I realing she's in a
different Paradigm you get what I'm
saying no so you know we talk about how
it's dumb and [__] this person
sounds but you have to think what kind
of an environment bred this kind of
person to listen to me I'm about to tell
you something important you're underr
for driving on the influence of
intoxicating alcohol and or drugs the
New Mexico implied consent act requires
you to submit to a breath test to
determine the alcohol content of your
blood after you take our test you have
the right to choose an additional
independent test if you choose to take
this additional independent test you
have the right to a reasonable
opportunity to arrange for a physician
licensed nurse or laboratory technician
or technologist who has employed by a
hospital or physician of your own choice
to perform an additional chemical test
the cost of this additional test will be
paid for by the law enforcement
agency I see you're shaking too cuz your
anxiety is bad just as mine yo you went
from anxiety to
Cockiness I see you got anxiety like me
we're both struggling this
together are you also being oppressed by
white
people maybe that's her way of flirting
that was a weird that's not a way of
flirting that's Cockiness that's
Cockiness y you're you have anxiety okay
yeah you're not you think you're good
you think you're you think you're all
right you feel good yeah no you're not
okay you have anxiety my anxiety is
taking half of me my
anxiety yeah yeah you have anxiety too
you're not as good as you think you are
so I'll continue on I cannot force you
to take our test but if you refuse
you'll lose your New Mexico driver's
license or non-resident operating
privilege for one year if you're
convicted in court of driving while
under the influence you may also receive
a great your sentence because you refuse
to be tested do you understand your
right to speak to an attorney or remain
silent does not apply to the requirement
of the Mexico law that you take a breath
test people
withes or no do you now agree to be
tested I'm just asking if it also
implies if people to anyone and everyone
that's arrested for driving Under the
Influence mhm so do you not agree to be
tested no I'm
just a yes or no ma'am I'm asking for
two breath samples no can you
what said we back the last two
paragraphs cuz I am severely depressed
so so I'm requesting you submit to a
breath test if you choose you can
request an additional chemical test that
will be paid for by us the law
enforcement agency I'll give you a
reasonable opportunity to arrange for
that to happen tonight um if you refuse
like I said I cannot force you to take
our test but if you refuse you lose your
nxo driver's license or non-resident
operating privilege for one
year okay so if I get a lawyer that do
not also so your right to speak to an
attorney or remain silent does not apply
to the requirement of the New Mexico law
that you take a breath test there you go
so do you agree to take our test no I
want a lawyer okay thank
you
545 what's that so can I just please
call my mom yeah I can do that for you I
have your phone do you have a wallet
that you want to go with you
tonight well I need to to it out my
pocket so I took your phone out of your
pocket okay well whoever the [__] was
that other [__] white ass
[__] oh nice yeah cuz racism
racism Works yes okay all right you can
run that [__] love it love it like I
said I got no sympathy I don't care
black why you know no I don't I don't
give a [__] if you drink and drive you
that's what I think pretty much you know
what I'm saying whatever happens to you
if you get caught drinking driving is
what happens to you you're not going no
sympathy for me you played yourself you
played yourself you want to play stupid
games you win dumb prizes it is what it
is that's my thoughts any else all right
now I'm going to go open a cold beer and
have myself a good night cuz I feel real
good right now and my dick needs a good
beating anything else you want to say
hey uh take care youself all
right
love them tears baby love them thank you
for watching
subscribe also in case you don't know we
have a Discord check it out we're there
all the time